we're rolling holy moly
[Laughter]
esther's back
wow
one of my favorite episodes truly was
your first step your first time on the
show last year was that last year yeah i
i had my doubts
and you ended up being one of my
favorite
thank you i will say that for the last
like 13 years i've watched and listened
to everything you've ever done so i do
feel like i'm the authority on
like just the lore of you like i know
everything like whenever i have a need
advice or direction i'm like no one
knows me better than esther
i've been studying you for years and i i
am like what should i do you know
you would know i mean i did have a
little meltdown after i did your podcast
uh yeah trash tuesday was that around
what was that's like a month and a half
ago two months ago yeah we recorded that
like right before the end of the year
and you were just you were like i don't
know what my next year plan is and
you're like you were like i need to just
figure it out and once i lock in i'll be
good well i think i was also having a
little bit of a like
being i'm so sick of myself like i don't
know what to say anymore like does
anyone give a shit about you know what i
mean i just feel like podcast you know i
don't really check numbers or comments
and maybe i should more because i would
have be able to ascertain
or like have some context of how things
are going or whatever i'm just like i
don't know if this is going well
i just feel like
i'm sick of bombing for two hours
talking about feelings like i don't know
i just was like i just felt very lost it
is going well and also i would say like
podcasting is like the the real secret
to it is the same where it's the real
secret to having good sex it's like do
it for yourself do it for three hours a
week straight
and make sure there's four cameras at
all times no do it for yourself like
like show up here and do what you want
and that's like and that's what you do
but i don't but but i don't comedians
we're trained to go like it is what i
want it is what i think is funny but
like the audience has the final say and
there's there's an involuntary response
in stand-up that's like oh they can't
fake that that's the truth whereas like
any time someone comes up to me just
like i love the podcast i'm obsessed i'm
like you have to say that like i have a
it's not imposter syndrome it's just i
think for me
i don't know i guess it just feels
self-indulgent sometimes
and
believe it or not that's something that
can makes me consumed with shame
then that does not consume me with shame
at all
yeah no i know i noticed i don't even
need
i know
i don't even need the audience to laugh
for me to feel go home and feel good
like that's not even
really part of my process
i know you're used to them laughing
that's you
um i'm now taking a little break
in um
trying to change esther's entire
personality
uh to talk about emily's period real
quick
because
we need to talk about a um
credit karma but emily just dropped on
me that jesus had her beard for six
months and
that when it comes out of her it goes
you guys have seen geysers right
geysers
you know a cartoon where you're like i
fly out of my chairs like that
do you want a new credit card but you're
not sure how to choose credit karma can
help find the right option for you
especially for someone like emily that
might need to go to a gynecologist
five months ago
uh this could be a great opportunity for
you to
pay someone to keep you alive can you
put your own funeral on a credit card
[Music]
their goal is financial progress for
their members no i'm gonna run your
funeral your body will be driving a car
into the funeral
this is where i shine and i'm going to
use credit karma to help me pay for it
credit karma partners with a wide range
of card issuers funeral homes probably
too so that you can be sure that you are
exploring all sorts of options are you
ready to find the card for you head to
credit karma and check out your
personalized mix of offers today go to
credit karma with the k.com or the
credit karma app to find the card near
you that's credit karma.com
uh that is for good karma uh speaking of
bad karma i am going to do more stand-up
shows we had to reschedule a bunch so
stay tuned
right this second because i'm about to
say i'm in like 20 seconds spoiler alert
this weekend i'm in portland oregon at
the arlene schnitzer concert hall that's
april 22nd april 23rd i'm in san
francisco california at the warfield
gorgeous venue these are the
that's the second to last show i'm doing
before i shoot my special in new jersey
may 7th i am going to be in toronto nope
nope i am flying i am technically going
to be in toronto may 7th the morning of
but i will be flying to vancouver also
on may 7th to perform at the vogue
theater in british columbia that evening
that's my last
show before i shoot my special in um may
13th and 14th in newark new jersey
live from newark victoria theater at the
pack new jersey pack that's where
whitney houston is from
don't watch the documentary about her
it's devastating okay speaking of
devastating i'm going back to where i'm
from on may 20th tyson's corner virginia
i'm going to be at the capital one hall
that's gonna be awkward because i feel
like i owe a lot of overcharges to
capital one bank i hope over traffic be
in the lobby yeah may 21st i'm gonna be
in the huntington new york uh paramount
theater i think that might be sold out
but uh
i'm sure i'll tweet something soon
that'll make you guys return your
tickets
on june 24th i'm going to be in calgary
prince island's park that sounds fake uh
is that what they call the new epstein
island um
oh
uh
what are the rides there
bummer it's prince andrew
june 26 toronto ontario why why on
because it's on that's the definition
like calgary's a b for alberta
vancouver's bc for british columbia they
have their own thing going on up there
nerd alert
be at the danforth music hall with this
little lady geography over here i'm
magellan oh old sally latitude over here
we have some rescheduled shows on
september 8th i'll be in cincinnati ohio
because i did uh miss my flight and that
was not my fault it's because one of the
pilots refused to get vaccinated and
didn't show up and i had to go to
cincinnati uh for no reason that night i
still i still went and i landed at like
10 p.m and i met ricky velez and we just
smoked weed in cincinnati ate chili it
was real it was a real uh rum spring up
september 9th i'll be in philadelphia
pennsylvania at the merriam theater i
went to college there all my exes come
through
uh september 10th i'll be in richmond
virginia at the national excuse me
that's where emily went to college all
my exes come through the ones that
didn't get a restraining order against
me is that your alma mal that's my alma
mater september 24th i'll be in
charlottesville virginia at the
paramount theater a lot of my family
members uh who are suing me will
probably be there can't wait enjoy this
program i was having like a big crisis
of confidence yeah
that is yeah i think that
that is very
like vulnerable to share and like i am
proud of you for like sharing a weakness
because i do view you as someone who is
so like no i'm not weak i'm too strong
i'm too good at stand up to be bad at
this and i just you know saying
i just uh i'm too good of a person to do
this well because i'm conscious of
wasting people's time and blathering on
in conversations that are aimless i also
i think the way you know my my brain is
very um
i get bored of what i'm saying halfway
through saying it yeah and i don't get
bored of what you're saying i want you
to keep going i feel like that is an
issue where i'm like wait what was that
like go back to that like you know what
it might have been
and you were you're uniquely qualified
because you witnessed this i think
during the pandemic
when it was like okay i'm just gonna
lean into podcasting because i mean
there was nothing else to really do and
i was like okay i need to like really
get good at this and whatever and it was
at a time when i was changing my hair
color i was taking edible and i just was
like i think there is such a thing as
over sharing and being too
uh transparent or vulnerable okay so you
you i would just get texts twice a day
like are you okay are you i have
something to say on this because
so you
it you've brought this up before like
you like during the pandemic you were
changing your hair color you were we get
it like if people were asking you are
you okay
i have such a different perspective of
what happened during the pandemic i was
so much crazier when i was a brunette
well that no i you like changed my life
for the better in a way that like it
almost is like unbelievable because i
was living in fear i was
and that
that i would have been living in fear
with or without the pandemic that was
just like the panama pandemic just like
made it clearer
but i was i had such severe anxiety and
it was like coming and doing your
podcast and then you like oh leaving the
door open for me to come back and just
hang out casually like because you know
there wasn't much to do and
you like
you like trained my brain to not live in
fear and you pointed out like hard facts
of like why the fear was bad for me and
you like created a safe space for people
to like hang outside it's aging you look
you look at least 19.
and so like i it always pains me when i
hear you talk negatively about that time
because i think of it as like
literally like changed the trajectory of
my whole life for the better and like
it's that's crazy i agree
i do think i've created a couple
monsters
i'm like why do you why do you have nine
inch fake nails why is your hair so long
we need to bring a little more fear and
insecurity back we need to bring a
little more anxiety back
is it possible you're too confident in
fearlessness
um but yeah just glitter on your eye
like your instagram feed has it has
definitely gone from like oh who me to
like butt up just like
but you know um
uh it's been cool to watch that well
that i feel like evolution of you is
more like
not being in my 20s anymore where you're
like the most desired sexually so you
just want to like hide yourself and now
that i'm in my 30s i'm like oh if
anything people just think it's sad that
i'm showing off my body so i'm like this
is the safe time to do it definitely not
for me
um i think now that i'm in my
like later 30s
i feel like i can go full sexy because
it's like people are proud of me exactly
opposed to like
being like oh she's using that to get
ahead or she's trying to steal my man or
she's so into herself like feeling
herself it's like oh no don't worry i
hated myself up until a couple years ago
now that i'm like getting older i'm
really into like
i mean i'm wearing like a velvet spandex
body so it's amazing and also that is
one of my favorite things actually about
kim kardashian is that she is 41 years
old and she is the hottest woman alive
yeah yeah yeah i'm like this is giving
me something to live for like
i i don't know i just feel like
i like that i'm a little older now and i
feel more confident to be sexy because
it's like
yeah it is it's i'm brave who says that
youth is wasted on the young okay
everyone yeah i just i fee i'm my dad
everyone feels weird i'm really glad you
uh brought up uh just the pandemic of us
being friends because
you knew me from before like i struggled
with girl friendships like i just had
ptsd around growing up with women that
were mercurial and scared me and i just
didn't have a lot of like
girl friendships that were with equals
and uh
and it was like really good practice for
me for us to sort of become friends but
me not feel the need to like
fix you or save you or rescue you or
like yeah
like you also
i actually wrote a list of like some of
the life-changing advice you've given me
because i feel like it'd be selfish not
to
um
one okay so the first which is my
favorite is the saying
that i always think of it's you you just
say tiger in a cage yeah and
i'll try to give
explain it but basically like if someone
is
starting shit with you or like coming at
you
for me i would always feel the need to
get involved and and figure and solve it
and like solve the problem
and
you told me like
that you're getting in the cage with a
tiger and the tiger doesn't want you to
solve the problem there's there is no
solving the problem they just want to
fight most likely and so the most
because you trying to solve the problem
they interpret as an attacker criticism
and there's no way that they're not
going to get defensive about it so it's
like in tiger in a cage real quick is
once someone has shown you who they are
consistently they have some kind of
trauma and now in the past and now as an
adult it manifests as uh
anger rage which is all just sadness and
fear we know that now but
anytime you have someone that is
truculent consistently like that you
just view them as a tiger we don't try
to change the nature of tigers we don't
try to compromise with them we don't try
to like people please them or love them
so much that they change their nature
once you know someone's nature
stick with it and don't get in the cage
with the tiger you can appreciate the
tiger from afar find the proximity that
is the safest for you but don't put
yourself in the cage with them close the
door and be stunned when they attack
yes and also my brain needs metaphors
like that same i learned that from you
and like so i also had to look at like
what's wrong with me because i keep
drawing the tigers in like i really do
and
i don't know if that's like childhood
circumstances or whatever it is like i'm
trying to work through and figure it out
but you're attracting it well you're
you're
you know
i'm not saying you're a doormat i'm
saying
that you
you will gladly i think if it's someone
that is like charismatic and beguiling
and fun and titillating and that's the
world we're in i mean we're around just
tigers all day incredible comedians
performers actresses musicians people
that are like professionally we the
world has voted that they're the most
charismatic people in the world
but that often you know charisma you my
therapist said to me once like charisma
is a red flag yeah like this is genuine
therapy for me i can't even believe
we're like doing it on a podcast but we
have to because i think it's helped me
so much i think it will help other
people but
but yeah i
i don't know what it is if i grew up
worshiping celebrities or like just like
a magnetic charismatic person i will do
whatever they say like
i will follow i will i just
and so when then when the fact that you
have not gotten sucked into scientology
yet is such a miracle the fact that
you're not in some wild sex cult
wow yeah and what's my and your and just
when i met you
there was there was some blur the
concept of boundaries i think was a
little
did not understand it at all blurry for
a lot of us didn't even know what it was
so people that are boundary-less are
like oh she's perfect for me yeah
because i was i had no boundaries either
like and and also which brings me to
another thing that you taught me which
is that boundaries
this is like mind-blowing this was my
mind when i heard it too
boundaries are
for me to set they are not for me to
tell you and they're for you to employ
yeah so
cause like
basically what that means is like it's
not up to me if somebody let's say
somebody calls me and i don't want them
to call me i'm not gonna say like don't
fucking call me ever again i'm just not
gonna answer because i'm setting the
boundary that i don't answer the phone
boundaries are for us not them yeah and
that is
mind-blowing and also such a gift
because it's like oh i'm in charge i'm
in charge of my boundaries i don't have
to
hope
that someone will follow them like
like honestly with my parents i had
they're the easiest example of like a
boundary that i had to set my parents
were a little bit too much talking about
sex in front of me
as a child no like recently like because
and i think it's because they were
watching trash tuesday and like we talk
about sex on that show so like they just
were like oh
like it's they thought it was okay and i
slowly realized wait this i hate this
it's making me so uncomfortable i and i
that one is different because i have to
say to them
don't do this
so that's a little bit it's also tricky
because i'm the first person to say
it's okay to be uncomfortable sometimes
depending on the circumstances you know
so it's like
no one should be violating your sp
whatever but life is about going okay
what discomfort should i learn to
tolerate
and what discomfort is actually like
violating depleting inappropriate
enabling to the other person
unprofessional whatever or that i just
don't want
family tends to be a different one yeah
because it's different
and then the idea of like okay and then
i set the boundary because i think that
sometimes when people you know uh like
people that i sponsor and stuff and alan
on as soon as they discover the magic of
boundaries they just start setting them
everywhere yeah don't talk to me you're
not it's like whoa you're also not
that's also being controlling and
domineering it's a tricky balance which
i'm the first to say like okay in that
situation maybe it's not about setting a
boundary maybe it's about
uh tolerating the discomfort tolerating
the discomfort or going like i don't
know as someone that doesn't have like a
nuclear family and parents and stuff
like that my brain kind of goes like you
know
if i was like sponsoring you i would
just be like oh or you can just laugh
about it and let them have the win and
you can be of service you know what i
mean
it's like you might be able to just be
of service because then you can build
your self-esteem by going like i
my parents my older parents that who
knows how much longer we're going to
have them how much more time i can spend
with them they're looking at their
motives they're not trying to upset you
they're not trying to i don't know
i look your mom i love your mom your mom
only wears my merch so i'm on i am on
her side forever
but it also might just sort of be like
okay
maybe the problem in that situation and
i'm happy to be wrong because i don't
know i would go
because idea of alan on and all this is
that we have choices you know what i'm
saying it's it's like i can set a
boundary i can remove myself i can just
experiment with tolerating this the idea
is that you have choices and not just
there's one reaction if you feel
attacked you can take a walk and go you
know what feelings aren't facts i'm not
being attacked i i
misinterpreted that situation no one's
trying to hurt me here i can just turn
it over and forgive and and no one's
intentionally trying to hurt me and i
think that that
the biggest struggle is going
just because i feel attacked just
because i feel judged doesn't mean i'm
being judged or just because someone
sends me an email and they put a period
instead of an exclamation point and you
go like oh well they're being fucking
rude and you're like wait no no i did
that yeah that was my fault um and being
able to separate intention and impact
because a lot of times the impact is us
that's our shit you know so i would go
maybe the maybe the solution is setting
the boundary for your parents saying i
don't want to talk about sex around you
it makes me uncomfortable but chances
are
what's your side of that like where's
what's your part in that of your parents
talking about sex in front of you well
you're making me realize that it's like
like they i think they're not i know
they're not doing it to upset me they're
doing it because it's funny to them and
that's like our
like the love language of my upbringing
is like laughter and so it's not coming
from a bad place they're just like want
to be funny and raunchy
and maybe that is
maybe they won't do it again because i
expressed to them i don't want them to
but if they do maybe i can be of service
and be like all right my parents think
they're funny whatever yeah and it's
also
but what what else is going on like what
do you feel when they're doing that
i just feel uncomfortable
i don't like it but what is the feeling
is it like a pit in your stomach is it
cringe is it shame is it embarrassment
maybe shame
i don't know if this is my own
interpretation of it or if i'm curious
if you feel this one too but like
sometimes or maybe it's more like my bad
mood is not me
so
i'll maybe i'll be in a really bad mood
because of it it could be anything it
could be an audition i didn't book it
could be a set that didn't go the way i
wanted to like although bad sets don't
bother me anymore but at all
so it's really not that one but
i could get in a bad mood for any given
reason i could have a stomachache
whatever and i could then be like i
don't want to do this i don't like what
i do i hate this i should quit stand up
i should quit the and i've learned over
the years to be like oh that's not who i
am that's my bad mood i'm curious if you
do you ever that's interesting yes so so
for me i think the the vernacular helps
me is my inner child reaction so it's
like when you uh you know what helps is
moving through the world going okay i
have my adult but when i'm hungry angry
lonely or tired we say halt am i any of
those things i mean i'm always those
always those things so that is
this reaction is coming from that but
it's easy for me to blame everybody else
other than look at myself and go okay
i'm hungry angry lonely and tired let me
go drink some fucking water let me go
have a snack get some blood sugar the
same way if a child was having a tantrum
or upset what's the first thing you
would say
do you want some water do you want to
take a nap yeah are you hungry because
if our carnal needs like that aren't met
we're going to
cause probably be more sensitive and
more reactive you know like 101 the way
we take care of others is to take care
of ourselves and the
the
sort of it's the irony i don't even know
if i'm using that word right but of you
know we put our oxygen mask on first
before the one next to us because we
can't
putting yourself first is how you put
other people's other people first that
is
so true that it's a mind-blowing concept
but it is so true it does nobody any
favors for you to come help me when
you're hungry angry lonely tired and
then you're mad at me you're gonna be
mad at me
and then you're like well i haven't
eaten today and you're like
why not
please don't let that be because of me
yeah exactly why no real friend would
want you to like starve yourself and not
sleep and then i assumed you were only
helping me because you had the time and
your cup runneth over and you had eaten
today you know like it's like when
people are like i have to go to this
baby shower i'm like
i would never want anyone doing anything
for me out of that obligation so if you
don't go to that baby shower with that
fucking attitude and stink up the room
just don't go yeah you know that is
really empowering because it's like the
martyr syndrome you're right i really
don't want
the help or the company if you don't
if you're if you're not happy doing it
why didn't you eat breakfast weirdo
the other thing that i have to mention
uh
that and this was actually before the
pandemic i want to say this was like
probably yeah it was like december of
2019 um i so i've always really
struggled with holidays yeah and
it was around that time when i was
talking to you about it just casually in
the green room at the comedy store and
you were like
yeah duh you just made me feel you're
like i struggle with holidays i have to
do this this and this like to make it
okay and
i've just always felt shame
and like sad that um the holidays really
freak me out like once christmas eve
comes around can you be specific is it
like an anedonia thing like i have
trouble enjoying something because i
know it's going to be over soon or
for me holidays the pressure the
pressure the pressure that this is
supposed to be a special day but i don't
even want it to be a special day it has
to be fun and i have to like if i'm not
having fun i'm not doing it right so
it's the emotional perfectionism of a
holidays coming around we're all
supposed to be super grateful and be
having the best time to be happy but
there's also these eggshells that are
around of like if i'm not like super
happy the whole time then i'm not doing
holidays perfectly and i have to be
engaging and charming and photogenic and
like
be the perfect uh happy person yeah and
i also don't like the feeling of just
because everyone around you is having
fun like why do i have i don't yeah me
too i don't i'm not i didn't go home for
christmas and so i
i stayed and you just invited us over
for christmas eve and like that was that
was a powerful re recreating a happy
time on christmas for me a low pressure
yeah i think you ordered literally like
kfc or something like that's right
or we did kfc like every fried chicken
option i'm like this is perfect like
well because
we also get to break the cycle and go i
don't have to do it the way my parents
did it i don't have to do not that they
like you know
you know no harm no foul god speed but
we also get to go like okay i don't have
to also
over give so much that
i'm never gonna feel like people
appreciated it enough because that's me
just setting myself up to be a victim
to re-embed and justify this like nobody
appreciates me nobody does enough for me
i love too much i do everything for
everyone and no one ever does anything
for me a lot of times when we like you
know over give
over
gift
over plan over decorate it's our way to
make it so that the scorecard will
always be
in our favor so no one can possibly ever
give us what we like deserve based on
how much we gave so that we can like
stay in a victim mentality yeah that's
just like safer and an old story that's
quite frankly like super boring because
then you can fall back on i did all this
i did all this for this person it's like
well no one asked you to do all that
yeah you that was you and you're just
setting us up to fail you know so i
think that we also probably grew up in a
time where it was like i grew up without
a lot of you know money so it was like
decorating it was a big deal to like get
christmas stuff and get gifts and then
you know
no harm no foul again our family was
very perfectionistic about like the
table and the food and the cooking the
fucking brisket for six days and the
thing and if you weren't like
this is the best thing i've ever eaten
they were like oh you know like it you
know it's like
i didn't realize i was walking into you
guys martyring yourself so much that if
i
you know didn't finish every
like crumb on my plate you were gonna
feel
slighted attacked yeah yeah that is that
is eye opening i relate to that a lot is
it called edmr when you do the buzzy
things emdr yeah emdr okay so i i used
to like spend a lot of time with someone
who
had a core belief about me that affected
me so this person would like often as a
joke of course but like refer to me as
being stupid
and i realized like after years of that
that i started to feel like oh well yeah
i'm not smart
and
i was like wait that's crazy i was i've
been smart forever what's going on how
is this happening and it was truly like
i always like compared to like
advertisements i'm like if somebody like
is advertising taco bell every day on
the tv you're gonna go get taco bell and
if someone every day is telling you
you're stupid you're gonna start to
believe it even if you think you won't
and you don't so
or if it's someone sorry that's got
that's either ostensibly an authority
figure or someone that you have sort of
the human magnet syndrome with someone
that's you know you're going to start
you've been cast in that role
and it was only because i had past facts
that i was able to pull up in therapy of
like i was in the gifted program like
i'm not stupid i know that and so we did
that where i had the buzzers of me like
basically going back to being told that
i was stupid and like and then just
telling myself no i am smart and it and
i have for a it's so lame but i wore a
bracelet that's just said smart on it
for a couple years and like i retrained
myself like i had to i had to advertise
to myself to like change that belief and
you know what and not to overthink this
but like making the connection back to
your parents making sex jokes there's
also i think you know a general shaming
in our business of like well if you're
doing jokes about sex like that's
low-hanging fruit and that's not smart
and you're not like there's maybe
there's also like residual ptsd from
that around like like your parents and
the sex jokes of like if you're making
sex you're basically just like saying
i'm stupid or this is the only thing i
can find comedy like i get defensive
about that too where
um because you can like just because
you're a woman talking about sex and
making jokes like that doesn't mean
you're dumb or can't do jokes about two
other
i don't want to talk about like global
warming and being tell people how to
vote like that is so fucking just you
know so i think there's also like like
whenever i feel uncomfortable around
someone or hurt i have to go like what
insecurity did that person just maybe
stumble into by accident
kind of thing like
so there's also yeah that because i have
a i have a big b in my bonnet over a
female comedian making sex jokes or joke
talking about sex
is like oh that's cheap or that's easy
it's like bitch nothing is fucking easy
as a female there's making someone laugh
for 60 minutes whether it's about sex or
about politics or about anthropology or
just whatever like is fucking impossible
but i have a little bit of a thing about
that
like if i'm talking about sex like i'm
not smart enough to talk about anything
else it's like no this is just that's
crazy this is just what's funny and
interesting to me yeah it's just you're
just being yourself yeah it's okay yeah
but that yeah that's really that's
really interesting because i think um
there's
and look as someone that wants to own
all the time that i am sensitive
when you're in a relationship with
somebody platonic
what uh or romantic
or familial like when someone says like
you're just sensitive
that's something that i care that was a
big thing that
that
made me uh a way to shame me that
back in the day that like that your
stupid thing was my you're too sensitive
i'm not abusing you you're just too
sensitive and i was like oh that's i'm
just too sensitive
you know if this this person is late or
disrespects my time or you know flirts
with my boyfriend or hypnotizing it's
brainwashing you believe it hey girl we
are now taking a much-needed break from
esther uh something i have to do all i
take breaks from her all the time i love
her so much but you know small doses my
nickname for esther small doses small
doses of a small lady
okay so this podcast as you know is
sponsored by better health better help
is committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change therapists if needed
this type of therapy online is more
affordable than traditional offline
therapy and financial aid is available
better help wants you to start living a
happier life today and so do i because
i'm sick of seeing your negative
comments and i'm sick of being like hurt
people hurt people fix it
special offer for good for you listeners
get 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com whitney no they
do not do speech therapy
emily i feel like after your week with
your family at disney world maybe you
know what i started communicating in
less than 48 hours and it couldn't have
come soon enough
betterhelp.com stop being crazy i'm sick
of lecturing you guys about this there's
no excuse anymore take care of your
brain take care of your bod
get your life on track it's enough
already we're done fix yourself fix
yourself you know else you can fix
yourself get your finances together can
i tell you nothing makes me grumpier
than being in when i had student debt
which went on for a very long time
because just when you think you're like
at the finish line the number gets
bigger again all of a sudden like it
it's like uh what is it something that
never goes down
no not whack-a-mole
but every time you think you're paying
it off it just the interest keeps it's
crazy you have to make such a big dent
in order to like get it's just a nice
it's just like you're suffocating it's
like you're in quicksand you know so i
think that like the psychological toll
this takes on us i see so many of my so
many my friends that are younger uh
buying stupid purses and shoes that are
giving them blisters but just
go to earnest.com get rid of your
student debt you can potentially save
thousands with refinancing by
refinancing you can reduce your loan
terms save money or combine multiple
loans into a simple monthly payment stop
buying the crystal water bottles dum-dum
with earnest it only takes two minutes
to see what your new rate could be and
there's no credit impact and right now
emily's gonna take over ernest is
offering our listeners a hundred dollar
cash bonus refinance your student debt
at earnest.com whitney not available in
all states once again you get a hundred
dollar cash bonus when you visit
earnest.com whitney to refinance your
student loan visit earnest.com whitney
for more details not available in all
states terms and conditions apply
earnest student loan refinancing made by
earnest operations llc nmls hashtag one
two oh
four
four four nine one seven california
financing light law license number
six oh five
four seven eight eight five three five
mission street san francisco california
nine
licenses for a full list of licenses
we went to college oh yeah guys not
worth it
not worth it
it's a girl
i'm going to say it as delicately as i
can but like being short
is a very real i've had a couple people
in my life that have had like
i'm not even joking i'm not even joking
and i'm happy to like be totally called
out on this the same way that being tall
has its own you know insecurities or
like uh maladaptive advantages like i
know a lot of people that are tall that
are like move through the world just
fucking up over and over again because
they have this like sense of confidence
that is totally based on the fact that
they could reach fruit from a tree 2 000
years ago that makes sense and i'm like
dude you're a mess you're like like you
have too much confidence like you just
think everything's gonna work out for
you because you were able to reach the
cereal like when you were a kid before
your brother no this is amazing because
i am the opposite of that i need help
but by the way i can't reach things and
my whole life i need oh can you help me
can you i can't and you are like
legitimately more vulnerable in a lot of
ways like taller people are more
vulnerable in some ways yeah you can hit
your head on the door frame or when you
fall it's
even worse or you could whatever but
like i had a a relationship with someone
very close work and um also
personal and this person was like always
thought i was trying to attack them
always interpreting things as criticism
always like defending herself when she
wasn't being attacked comes from a
pretty safe
childhood and like i couldn't figure it
out like everything was like i mean like
crying like scared and i was explaining
it to you know my therapist george at
the time and she just out of nowhere she
was like is she really short
why and i was like
yeah actually that's so weird to say she
is short i was like what is okay and he
was like well yeah like you're you are
more vulnerable in a lot of ways like
just period the end and it's something
that it's like i'm sorry am i not being
sensitive to the no vertically
no diverse you're making a great point
but it's just a way to go like oh
because i see a lot of you know uh
friends of mine that are
of tiny people and they're like i don't
know i have all this anxiety and i have
this and i need to be on this and this
is like yes maybe totally but also like
what are just the kind of like
biological impulses that make us
when i think when you're like i'm scared
of course you're scared
why wouldn't you know what i'm saying of
course like i have different fears for
other reasons about stuff but like you
know uh being small and the time that
you got to be a certain height like you
can kind of go back and do forensics and
just go like oh yeah in general you are
in a little more danger like period i
also think that that
because i even my best friends we we
call it like hashtag help esther like i
always need help and that could come
from like just the same you like to rely
on people like you did and you're an
only child right i have might have a
older half sister okay god was in the
house with you yes okay so yeah it had
to be like i want that cereal can
someone help me or you had to like step
on the stove or you had to get a chair
it's not my fault i'm needy
seeming needy is like a really scary
fucking embarrassing thing needing help
you know which is why i think i see why
you are attracted to people that are
very um
dominating and
i don't want to say aggressive but just
very like
um big personalities big personalities
people that
when shit hits the fan
you want to be with that you want to be
on that person's side yeah so a lot of
times that's so it's like i'm looking
for safety and these ironically really
dangerous people yeah because like if
there was a i want this person on my
side because this is the most
unpredictable
fearless
uh
person but the irony is the more i try
to get close to them to get that
sort of subconscious sense of safety the
more danger i'm in yeah i'm sure that
also a lot of women seek that out in
romantic relationships too totally
totally i don't know why for me it was
never a romantic thing it's more just
like people in life but absolutely
you're nailing it it's almost like
making me uncomfortable it's like
embarrassing but yeah like
the scary person if they're on my side
is that's
like i'm gonna jump i'm gonna align with
all these people that could be a danger
to me because i feel safe with them but
the irony the closer i am to them like
i'm now
you know but uh it is interesting though
that you because i have all this too but
i
you had some darwinian instinct to
be in a relationship with someone that
is not
i don't know what that is it's wild
i i should not give myself the credit
because i do think i just got lucky
esther is with the
healthiest healthiest most wonderful
hilarious by the way my first boss so
weird and it's like the fact that you
haven't sabotaged that or fucked that up
and you're able to receive that kind of
love i tried for many years to ruin it
and he just wouldn't let you he's like
he makes the joke he's like i should
have broken up with you years ago but
he's like i'm
but i'm like but you're glad you didn't
right he's like yeah now it's fine but
let me check my notes if there's any
other
uh
i well okay these were two advice
questions i have for you
which is like because i'm i feel like
we're similar in the fact that like
working feels really good and we like it
but then
sometimes you're too burned out to bring
your fullest self like so do you have
advice for like how to handle burnout
and like how to replenish yourself so
everyone's is going to be different so
like when i talk about like how to like
you know uh uh rejuvenate yourself this
these might not be things that work for
everybody but i also am you know people
every
time i see someone like oh my god you're
like so crazy busy like i don't even
feel like i should ask you to do
anything
and i'm sorry based on what my instagram
looks like and i'm like that's so ironic
because i
i like take naps i sleep eight hours
like i do work my ass off and it is
super hectic but the way i make my
schedule on sundays and stick to it and
in i schedule in um
eight hours of sleep and a nap slash
meditation like i feel i mean
sometimes like i'm lazy oddly but i'm
like the only reason i can get all this
done is if i'm like rested and my carnal
needs are met i schedule in exercise and
value it just as m and sauna time just
as much as i do the work because the
work's gonna suck if i'm not at a
hundred percent oh yeah so it's like i
schedule in being a hundred percent i
also don't take on same-day plans i
don't take on new stuff i don't i
learned that from you too actually i
don't take because cut and i also get
ahead of decision fatigue so for me
because of my perfectionism and like a
little
dallop of ocd
i pick out all my clothes for the week
on sunday and make all my decisions
sunday so that i'm not doing game time
decisions right before things and then i
know what you're thinking right now with
my outfit you're like that must have
taken hours to put together but i do it
ahead of time so that right before the
podcast or right before i go to stand up
or right before we're shooting you know
tick tocks or whatever we're doing i'm
going i should wear this but i shouldn't
wear this but i should wear something
from esther's line so that i can tag
esther but like oh my friend just teddy
fresh they just had a thing come out so
i should wear
that hoodie so i can tag it and take a
picture because then i'm in exhausting
myself yeah and i and you just have to
know what depletes you and get ahead of
it you know so i do no um same-day
decisions if someone's like hey can i
swing by even if it's someone i want to
see i'm like
i didn't a lot i love it for spending
those energy dollars so for me energy
dollar energy dollars so how many energy
dollars do you have a day so you say i
have 100 energy dollars you have to know
how much
uh it takes energy wise for you to do
certain things and then a lot so if by
10 a.m
i've gone on instagram and gotten
jealous of a bunch of people and
responded to all of it and then it's
like oh well this person and and then
i've spent okay i did not plan on
spending 10 energy dollars by 10 a.m but
i did and that's where we are so now i
have to kind of course correct my day
because then if like and then i've okay
i'm gonna it's gonna take me 50 energy
dollars to do the podcast 30 energy
dollars do this thing afterwards and now
we're at five o'clock and i'm out i've
spent all my money and then i either
need to cancel the thing i have tonight
forego something i was gonna do or else
i'm gonna start borrowing from tomorrow
i'm gonna go you know what i'll just
i'll just do that tonight and then
tomorrow i'm going to start at 80 energy
dollars i am so excited to go home and
like plan this shit out because i needed
to hear this so hardcore and also
similarly what i learned from you a
couple years ago which i have like just
now started implementing is like
i don't
take facetime calls during the day
anymore like if my friends just want to
like randomly talk to me for two hours
like i don't do that anymore that was
like a codependent thing like
then i'm and now my day is all about
that person it's like what am i doing i
need to focus on of course you have fear
and anxiety because it's like then it's
like well it's two o'clock and i haven't
got anything done yeah all i've done is
kind of
responded be this person's solution to
their boredom like it's sort of like if
you want to try for two hours we need to
schedule that like yeah we should have
scheduled like three months ago by the
way i love chatting on the phone i love
it yeah but for me i've learned i like
doing it at night i don't like middle of
the day yep okay well yeah that sounds
weird that's how i am now i'm gonna go
with it totally
also going on prozac not saying you know
obviously no if you need to be on an
antidepressant but i was for me
no antidepressants really worked for me
i didn't really feel like i had
depression but i did waste a lot of time
and energy
um perseverating and like worrying about
things or like i'd have a conversation
with someone and be like why'd you say
that that was so dumb or you should have
done this and you should have said that
and a lot of that is just like a loop
that comes that prozac
solved for me that
mine was lexapro which i know didn't
work for you
works amazing for me miracle changed my
life i'm on a low dose five milligrams
game changer and you openly telling me
that you took prozac and that was so
helpful for me because i'm like i look
at you and i'm like i see this woman who
has it all like has all the career
success is so smart
but she needs some help with her mental
health so then it must be fine that i
need it too so that was helpful because
i it would i know i talk about it a lot
but i just feel it would be selfish of
me to not fully be transparent that the
lexapro
changed my life
that i was so anxious and not living
like a normal person should and it's
it's really sad yeah and figuring out
what's handicapping you and paralyzing
you from being able to like fully
participate in your life and enjoy
things and like you know there's lots of
side effects a lot of these things so
you have to kind of look and go like
this is just where i am today but i feel
very like energized by not worrying
about things that i can't control
yeah you know and obsessing over what
people think about me because it's just
like
draining draining i also the social
media stuff like i i mean during the
pandemic it was like we were just on our
phones all the time and just making
content and podcasting like i i really
can't i can really only do like 10
minutes in the morning and 10 at night i
put my phone in grayscale which is you
know makes it less attractive and in
general you're
less addictive so it's just in black and
white i have to go back to color when
i'm taking a picture or doing an ig live
or something like that but
for me the phone is a real brain drain
not only because you're staring in light
and you're basically like you know
adrenalizing yourself unnecessarily but
then you don't know if you're gonna see
a picture of your ex or get jealous
because someone got something you wanted
or just i just had to really like
you know for the longest time i was like
i should be able to go on instagram and
not get activated or jealous or feel all
these feelings and i'm like instead of
going on and practicing being numb i'm
just gonna go like you know what
you don't know what you're to walk into
emily rajagowski's in a bikini
fucks up your whole day or you're like
you know or whatever you see they're
like i auditioned for that movie i
didn't get it
like you never know what land mine
you're going to walk into that's going
to drain you so i've really had to play
defense on the phone stuff that's cool
and that is inspiring to me because it's
like you
you set a boundary for yourself almost
like you're like this is making me feel
bad so i'm gonna stop doing no mindless
scrolling anymore i can't do it i've had
to mute a couple people that i
love with all my heart
but it was making me dread seeing them
or talked to or it just gave me this
false sense of attuning and socializing
it'd be like wow i know what this
person's up to i don't need to go have
coffee with them when it was like when
in reality just sitting down with them
and having social time actually
energizes you better for your mental
health i found myself like losing
respect for a lot of people that i
really liked just
because and i'm sure a lot of people
have done that with me too you know it's
like social media we kind of have to
average it's just it's a business tool i
know i always say that i'm like in my
head i'm always thinking that if i if
the insecurity recreates and i'm like
this isn't for my friends no
mute me you should not follow me
please mute me yeah because you know
there's like the hatery comment like
your instagram is all pictures of you
and i always want to be like duh well
yeah exactly but it's also like i'm on
here to try to entertain people and be
fun and funny and like that might not be
how i hang out with a friend all the
time but it is what the product i'm
selling and i refuse to be like
boring on my instagram just because i'm
trying to
look cool
what's the easiest analogy is like are
you doing your set on stage for the
audience or for the comedians in the
back of the room
and who don't buy tickets exactly so
like i'm doing it for the crowd yeah
yeah totally hey guys we now take
another break from esther because that
is really what makes a relationship with
both of us work
breaks
i want to talk about monday.com everyone
asks me how i am so productive no it's
not adderall not because i don't want to
take it just because there's a shortage
in los angeles
monday.com is this flexible platform
much like the
thing that my dog just knocked over
that's more flexible than i thought it
was going to be this platform allows
teams to customize work software to
their needs integrate all your favorite
tools and apps into one central platform
to unify your work collaborate across
teams and departments why do i feel like
vladimir putin uses this
because he's very organized you know
what say what you will say what you will
get done
to start your free two-week trial go to
monday.com podcast that's monday.com
podcast okay so here's the deal with
monday.com i
i think of myself as a pretty organized
person i just feel like you have to pick
a workflow when there's a lot of
different personalities and this helps
you customize it to the type of
personalities that you work with what
you need we have kind of wild hours um
a dog just farted it can't help you with
that but go to monday.com
podcast and get your work life in order
get it done it's like
oh my god that's a pretty serious fart
i'm gonna put on my monday.com to-do
list to get that dog on some
gas x
i'm gonna put on my monday.com to-do
list to get a new
podcast show runner and host who can
handle
a little shit
it smells like actual shit did he shit
pat came in today and he picked up a
cord
it was dried shit
oh
i'm so sorry pat oh we're sorry to pass
i'm sorry
we're gonna start putting on our
monday.com thing before anyone gets your
whitney just clean up all of the yeah
under your to-do list
studio oh my god oh speaking of things
that my dogs have ruined bowl and branch
uh i'm obsessed with my 100
organic cotton luxury bedding and bath
okay let me be clear about something
both of us have
depression and nothing is more important
to people with depression than bedding
and bath items oh that is so true so
this one i have okay so i just if you
guys have seen my horse bedroom i
decorated a bedroom that's all horse
stuff and i wanted this exact color for
the sheets but look it's what is it even
it's like a putty sort of color amazing
okay so this is
here's my deal with sheets
it not only does it have to be soft blah
blah it has to feel a little cold when
you lie yeah and these have that i've
been taking them on the road with me i
send them ahead of time i am that beach
and i got a blue pair and they're so
deep that i don't have to like fight
with the mattress while i'm putting it
on one side and the other it's like okay
don't talk about sex with your boyfriend
pillow right now because that is not
what polymerance makes okay this is
something she covers her boyfriend
pillow in bowling branch and pretends
it's a man and we'll get that's a
different and you know what he still
doesn't text me back and like what i
love about it is it's toxin-free and
family-owned
business partners business unlike this
business we are family free we are
family free and owned by the saudis yes
miss the bowling branch april sale our
listeners get an exclusive access to
post-sale 20
site-wide discount through the end of
april with promo code at
bullandbranch.com that's bull and branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot com promo code for 20 off
through the end of april made ethically
in india yes
well thank you a dream a dream ah um
okay so i also want to um i wanted this
episode to just be like nurturing on
every level and just for people to um uh
turn it off with like i'm gonna change
the way that i do this and i got an idea
of how to you know uh
amend this with my family or make better
choices in this way and like this is
just like jamming in solution episode
and also i never talk about my skincare
routine people ask me all the time
you're one of the few people i feel like
i can really dig in because you're a
product tour in the best way i'm i'm
dying for this moment especially the
updated version because we haven't had
this conversation a couple years i want
to do first of all just like speed round
of life hacks in general of things that
have helped me change my life that i
would be a selfish bitch for not sharing
so all of our skincare products none of
it is absorbing into your skin if you
haven't exfoliated your skin or if you
haven't micro needled or what um i
really want to know about micronutrients
derma roll
so here's the thing we have the top
layer of our skin is mostly dead skin so
when we put our products on we're kind
of just like caking onto
it's not really absorbing you know into
our skin most of it unless you've
exfoliated unless you've done some kind
of astringent you know this the lotion
p50 or p70 by biologic research i use a
lot um the uh skin eternal serum um uh
with alpha lipoic acid in it um that i
do source naturals we are those to
exfoliate that removal i put them on on
top after i've derma rolled okay so this
is a derma roller this is the one that i
use um and it's just like a little tool
that has little tiny needles in it
that before i apply any of my product
i'm always going to micro needle not or
derma roll micro needling micro needling
is that's actually when you go to like a
facial list and it's a needle that has a
little bit of electricity in it and they
make little holes in your face and then
put stuff on it and it what it does is
it um
creates a little trauma in your uh
epidermis so that the because the trauma
response is producing collagen and
that's what tightens everything okay so
this was my question because i heard
david sinclair talk about microneedling
and how it's anti-aging yeah does derma
rolling do the same benefit or do you
need to get microneedling microneedling
i i would just you know if you're
microneedling with the wrong person it's
not going to do
a ton i do ulthera so ulthera is a emily
did it with me in uh at doctor so
conover wellness in um south carolina uh
kelly conover and dr conover she's like
just such a gangster and did an
incredible job so for the past like six
years i've done ulthera once a year
which is like a laser that traumatizes
uh your skin so intensely that it starts
producing collagen which is what
tightens everything so micro needling i
think does the same is the idea it does
the same thing i haven't done it enough
to be able to speak to it but i did do
micro needling a couple times and they
put like stem cells or some kind of like
you know
your own prp from your blood is what
they try to say to do but so for me
that's something that look i don't get
facials i don't go to facialists like i
just it's too time consuming for me and
the stress it would cause to go get the
facials every week yeah to drive there
that ages you know stress is what ages
you so i for what works for me is i do
this um derma rolling and then put the
product in every night i just think
something you're doing every day is a
regular thing is to have a bigger impact
and going like i'm going to just sort of
like treat my skin like shit and then
once a week get a facial yeah you know
so i try to not rely on something to fix
what could have just been maintained on
a daily basis so i think this is a
better way to do it to just derma roll
every night never do it in the morning
because uh you're gonna go on the sun in
some capacity but you also have to build
up a tolerance to it so when you first
have you ever use that no like
like
yeah so it's like it's it's gonna feel
wonky and especially over your lips but
make sure when you derma roll you never
skip your eyebrows right under your eyes
over your lips right and then under your
neck and your neck and this jawbone
because a lot of times we try to just
put product on our foreheads
on our cheeks and chin you're like well
you're missing your lips you're missing
your the skin under your eyebrows you're
right i never do that and sort of stuff
like that so it's like it's just this
has changed my life i use uh
and as you know i'm not a big fancy
product person i make my own skin oil
from grape seed oil
i have my own little weird combination
but i just get grape seed oil from whole
foods and you know that i don't really
wash my face that much i never get water
on my face i always wash with grape seed
oil like i'll sometimes use like a you
know some kind of like
you know this the m essence this is my
favorite thing on the planet i actually
found this out chelsea handlers makeup
artist back in the day sprayed it one
time and i was like what is that smell i
just was like that's the most incredible
thing i've ever smelled and so sometimes
i'll just rinse my face like with that
if i need to
spray it it's my favorite smell
oh that is really what is that
like what is that it's like smells like
grass it's like clean smelling it just
smells like grass or something it smells
like the earth so i'll sometimes like do
that to just you know but um in general
i use oil to wash my face before i get
in the shower or wash my face i always
put oil on first i've started using do
you know this brand capari oh yeah this
coconut milk to take your makeup off yes
that is you can probably just use
straight up coconut oil which is what i
would probably use like you can just
olive oil coconut oil grapeseed oil the
stuff you actually cook with i a lot of
times honestly this might really just be
coconut oil repackaged but it's just but
it's like a cute packaging and it's like
you put it on your face to kind of melt
your makeup off let it dissolve and then
i'll just use a um
uh uh
what's it not a dish towel what's the
face wash cloth to just yeah just take
it all off i needed to hear this today
because i have been just relying on face
wash to get my makeup off and when i
tell you it doesn't work no no it is and
you're just destroying your
skin really well i mean it depends on
what kind of like if you're just like
washing trying to describe it's better
to put
so oil dissolves dissolves oil so if you
put oil on top of it it'll just start to
dissolve and then you can just gently
take it off with a face towel this is i
need to this is what i need to do yeah
because i am like i'm like lying to
myself when i wash my face and then i go
to bed with i know the makeup is still
on there it's gross yeah yeah i would
just like put oil all over it let it
dissolve and then you can take a face
wash if you want but i think there's so
much fear around oil i think a lot
there's this like um you know fallacy
that
oil is gonna give you zits and oil is
gonna break you out and stuff like that
but it took me a long time to learn like
if you're using oil on your face
consistently the oil glands are uh in
your skin are gonna stop producing so
much oil yeah so it's actually gonna
help stop breakouts that's what fixed my
cystic acne is i started just like
lathering my face with oil three times
isn't that crazy that like your whole
life that you were probably taught like
oil free like dry your skin out but that
just made it worse it's the same thing
with fat going like fat makes you fat no
totally the opposite yeah it is so good
for you i was running around like having
sugar-free snack while sugar-free
everything fat i'm sorry fat-free
everything but then you're just eating
tons more sugar you're like you know and
like and i'm
so tricked yeah i'm fat and like i'm
only eating fat-free stuff you know um
but uh but that's big and then also i
know this is gonna sound psychotic it is
what it is take what you like leave the
rest which is that you know that i
reapply uh my products in the middle of
the night when i get up and go to the
bathroom this is iconic and also the way
you sleep don't
derma roll put all these products on
your face have i'll absorb 20 minutes
later lay down on your pillow and have
all of it wipe off on your pillow like
you're just anti-aging your pillow and
your moisture your pillows are the most
moisturized things in your house yet
your skin is like molting off so i sleep
on my back with noise canceling
headphones so that i don't my cheek
doesn't hit the pillow and wipe off all
the product
and i also do the sleep crown pillow
under my neck what is that you know the
sleep crown it's what you um it's
incredible it's a it's a pillow that's
kind of like mushy and always cold
somehow uh and if you put it over your
eyes
and around your ears it blocks out all
light and sound but you can also put it
under your neck
but it's like
not like one of those hard ones that you
get at the airport yeah it's incredible
i can't live without i'll give you one i
have a whole closet full of them i take
them everywhere it's like the only way i
can function um and uh so i make sure
that i'm sleeping on my back and that uh
i'm not like you know wiping off all my
product on my pillows and then in the
middle of night when i get up to pee
i've got my oil pump right next to my
toilet
at all times so when i get up to pee in
the middle of the night i can just like
reapply your like skincare philosophy
feel it's just like always stay wet
always stay lubed up and you know where
i got it from i mean you know not only
the trial and error and such but also
growing up um my aunts when i lived in
roanoke i would have to polish the
saddles the horse saddles and the idea
like in order to keep leather
from cracking you have to you keep it
out of the sun you have to keep it
constantly oiled up like and it's just
and my aunt said to me once like your
skin is like leather it's the same thing
just treat your skin the way that you
would treat leather and it was like oh
don't get it wet don't let it get wet
and then dry
because that's gonna make it age and
like crack up and don't put it in the
sun and make sure that it's always oiled
up and inside in the shade in a human
environment a humid environment so also
like humidifiers is a big thing too
whenever i have to like work in offices
and stuff i always have humidifiers
whoa okay so like because you obviously
your face has to get wet like when you
go in the shower and stuff so you what
you do is you just apply
i'll have oil first before i get in the
shower yeah if i'm gonna like sit in the
bathtub or something like that or if i'm
gonna get in the shower i'll put oil on
first because your skin game is next
level like you okay your skin is great
like you're 88 years old this by the way
tomato seed oil doesn't really matter
what brand has uh uh someone told me
about it like six years ago started
using it incredible um so yeah uh grape
seed oil carrot seed oil but before that
i will always do a moisturizer um which
i love the milk moisturizer it's vegan
this one is really moisturizing
um
most moisturizers i feel like my skin
like eats it up in like 20 minutes that
i always use under my foundation and
then i started using this um
lila b priming oil
it's a it's a bronzing priming oil
fancy i clean yeah i put under my makeup
now i do i don't know a ton about that
brand it's it's like she's super clean
and premium it's cool i actually brought
um
i brought some stuff too to show you
okay good because then another oil that
i do like if you're like
gonna get a fancy oil which i'll do
sometimes i'll have it on the plane with
me i like vintner's daughter
this la prunier this is what nova our
makeup artist uses it's the pressed
prune oil from the like this is
incredible super clean also has natural
spf and then this has been my favorite
for so long it's called african
botanicals neroli infused marula oil oh
that is so good smell it it is my
favorite smell on the planet so that
oh my god yeah i've used this at your
house before i love this this is my
favorite smell it's on the planet and oh
i also someone just sent me this honey
infused face oil gesso
you i like that too pharmacy with an f
also has a good uh honey face oil
so i feel like the philosophy is really
just stay keep your face oily as hell at
all even in the middle of the night at
all times like what because
yes it makes total sense though when you
think about it yeah no the leather
analogy is like scary how
it's it's just scary also get your stuff
out because i also was gonna say milk
also does this grip primer i've never
done this had one of these before it's
you put you spray it on your face after
you do your makeup and it just like
holds your makeup in place oh wow and it
makes it so you're like like eyeliner
doesn't run and you don't start turning
into the joker or like a
you know
jackson pollock painting 10 minutes in
so i started using that too and i really
like it all right what do you have
because i'm going to keep going i so i
just brought my favorite moisturizer um
which is the drunk because i'm a dry
skinny i like
it it's a drunk elephant f-bomb like
that has been my release let me see let
me have because they have a mask that i
really like baby it's baby
facial baby facial that's yes that one's
a little bit adrenochrome
chrome one
i mispronounced it that's a good sign it
means i don't use it also do you know
this company beauty stat no this this
has uh absorbic acid and 20 vitamin c
this
i
think things work based on how much they
hurt
when i put them on and that is like a
little tiny peel that
i really like well so
oddly enough the person because i've
obviously taken in so much skin care
advice like over the years and
the what has rejuvenated
my interest in skincare is actually
david sinclair who i learned about on
your podcast he has a podcast and he did
like his anti-aging like um
for your appearance episode and he
pointed out like the ingredients that
are scientifically proven to work which
is retinol uh-huh um
i'm like is that it i think you
mentioned hyaluronic acid yeah but
that's not really like anti-aging
necessarily it's just super moisturizing
yeah but so that is why i got recently
interested in retinol do you use it i do
use retinol i didn't for a long time
yeah uh because uh for a litany of
reasons like it was i was getting
using retinol is great yes but if you're
also in the sun all the time and you're
doing lasers that thin your skin or
you're doing skin bleaching creams
you're doing something else that's
really abrasive it can backfire so you
just for me i retinol backfired on me
really when i was in my 20s because i
had acne and i was kind of i was putting
all these drying agents on it to try to
dry out all the acne and i'd put
toothpaste on and i'd put on salicylic
acid and i would be in the sun all the
time i was going to tanning beds like
so
i think if you're taking care of your
skin and protecting it and not thinning
it in other ways retinol really worked
for me okay works for me now okay but
didn't before when i was like thinning
and damaging my skin in other ways and i
i didn't understand i blamed it on the
retinol when i was like oh no i'm also
putting on salicylic acid i'm
not hydrating properly i'm in the sun
all the time that plus retinol is not
too much it's not always good yeah you
have sensitivity i know you have to be
careful with retinol yeah for sure yes
you have to like build up a tolerance
and know what you're doing yeah yeah but
that one yeah i got so i'm like i just
got different because it's like a it's
available at literally walgreens is that
a for a diaper rash it's a red it's a
retinol
gel
okay
my like acne treatment okay it's 0.01
percent the retinol i get is from
conover aesthetics and then i also
brought my um
d my vitamin d drop nice okay this is
athletic greens yes
this is just made like taking vitamin d
actually but do you put it in something
or you just drop it on your chocolate it
only tastes like olive oil yes they sent
me this okay this is good well i do
athletic greens every morning just a
scoop in i know i'm supposed to do water
i've mixed it with like pineapple juice
or fruit juice that sounds good put it
in a smoothie and it's just it's
so good i would do that yeah and
sometimes i mix it in like like coconut
yogurt or something i'll just take the
spoonful of it mix it in and it's like a
little like pudding but i've see they
sent me this but i hadn't used it yet
okay this one because i just do a drop
on your i just yeah but see like because
your vitamin
thing kind of stresses me out i need to
go one at a time vitamin k that's good
that's good yeah supposedly helps you
absorb the d this is a little something
that um uh kelly conover sent me
i-s-d-i-n skin cuticles melatonin
i can't even tell you what's in it but
it's incredible it's been amazing for my
skin it's like a night serum
i don't know i've noticed a change in my
skin because i'll go okay wash your face
then i'll do the derma rolling i'll do
my alpha lipoic acid dmae esther c then
i'll do a serum usually this one then
i'll do and i i spend 10 minutes between
each one i'll put on the serum and then
i'll go do some something for 10 minutes
come back then i'll do moisture let that
soak in for 10 minutes then i'll come
back and then i'll do my like final oil
wow
this is mind-blowing it's like always
but it's just
for me it's it doesn't take that much
time because it's such a routine i do
this and then i turn the lights off and
then i do this moisture then i can let
the dogs out like it's just kind of part
of my well also i bet it looks like
german it doesn't it make you feel good
too like you know that you're doing
something for yourself to be better and
like it just that probably makes you
feel confident because i also again it's
like to be able to do all this at home
has and just accepting it and finding a
way that it's not like so time-consuming
and exhausting or you can do it while
you're watching tv just bring a little i
have all these little basket thingies
like sit and watch tv put one on let it
sink in 10 minutes later do another like
find something else to do when you're on
the phone or facetiming with someone
like it's not time consuming because
i've just learned to accept it and it's
taken off so much stress of getting
facials every week worrying about do i
get lasers do i do this like daily
maintenance has saved me so much time
that is i feel like almost the headline
for me here because it i
it has to be something that is going to
make you feel good and be easy and not
add more stress because i will be the
first person to get really stressed out
when i think like i should be doing this
facial and i should be doing and i don't
want to go do that like i do want
something to work with me yeah like and
for me that's like i'll put a little
retinol on at night i do my moisturizer
like i did my part yeah and i'm not
going to stress about the things i'm not
doing yeah yeah yeah what sunscreen do
you use i i have a couple i use like um
i'll use like the tower 28
tinted sunscreen yeah i like that brand
and then um
ilia has one
like i just for me i like i like less
products so i like something that's
gonna like kind of give me a little bit
of a cover up well ilia has a tinted one
yeah yeah i have that too and so does
hourglass hourglass oh i haven't tried
hourglass has my favorite tinted um like
sunscreen also has uh hyaluronic acid in
it uh also
uh julep j-u-l-e-p yeah it's called no
excuses and it's a gel
that you can put under your makeup or
whatever and it's just like it's not
greasy it's not gross because you know
somebody's with sunscreen on and then
everything you touch for the next two
days it's just fucking comforting like
like shmegma so that one i love and then
i love the sun bum it's like a stick
that's like i'll put on my hands and
like under my eyes and on my lips and
mouth and stuff and you i'm assuming
you're very good about your sunscreen
you do i'm psychotic you know i wear
gloves to drive
i have driving gloves too i have driving
sleeves i should do gloves i used to put
these like sleeves on that would cover
my arms in the summer well you're
missing a nail i know that is such a
bummer i hate in the fact that i noticed
i hate myself but it is like the reason
i don't get gels and presses no i know i
have this like last draw it looks
amazing until one is gone i know and
that's all i can think about it's so sad
i'm gonna fix it today okay i ca i
mostly don't have long nails because i
can't like squeeze my skin and and
squeeze like every little fucking hole
um okay so then uh what else do you have
and then we'll wrap up soon i did want
to point out that my favorite fragrance
child
is
everybody always asks what perfume i i
collect perfume i'm obsessed with
perfume i have a different one for every
mood i am like very big on like smells
olfactory glands like if i need to feel
confident i'll wear a certain thing if i
that is beautiful smelling the fact that
it's called child it takes a second to
be like this is not like a doesn't smell
like a baby but when i
you can only wear that if you're
prepared for everyone to like fall in
love with you yeah and ask about it
every time i wear it people what is that
it's like a whole thing when you wear it
but i finally decided i'm gonna admit
all my little tricks of the trade and
secrets and child is one of them
it tastes like a taste i also drink it
sometimes uh when i when i can't have my
night night juice um it's like a mix of
like smelling like hawaiian tropic like
coconut
like like
sun oil like when you were a kid it does
have that and like member um loves baby
soft remember that yeah perfume which i
was obsessed with that i still wear and
white musk from the body shop i still
wear those sometimes um but there's
something about it where
it like triggers some memory for people
of like the beach or it does it's
something it smells like
hawaiian tropic or like bullfrog summery
but not overly summery smells like
tanning oil like banana boat tanning oil
yeah i love that it's the only way to
describe it
what else that's all you brought i so
yeah like my i've really stripped down
my routine to literally just a really
great moisturizer and a retinol three
times a week or whatever and then
obviously the sunscreen in the morning
and the tinted one i
also what else did i bring oh i brought
this osei because it's just a
hyaluronic yeah yeah and i like that
brand a lot
o-s-e-a they have a lot of good like
serums and body these i take on the road
because i find that like i
the the soaps in hotels either make me
really happy or really sad yeah usually
they make me really sad stripping so
this is it's this new brand called plus
and it's like by everything is
biodegradable so you literally like rip
this open it's a go ahead yeah it's like
a like a soap sheet it's a sheet of soap
this the packaging you just throw it
down the drain it disintegrates and then
you like and it smells good holy shit
it's like just a way on the road where
i'm like i'm going to treat myself with
it that's genius
that is genius yeah i know it's like the
soaps and hotels it's like you've
stripped all the moisture from your body
and you're not even clean like it's just
sort of like it's like i don't feel like
i bring my exfoliating mitts so the
mitts that are like gloves that are
exfoliating so i now bring those on the
road with me because that is the only
and it's also good for like lymphatic
drainage to do like under your um uh uh
what's this thing i'm touching right now
your lyft notes your neck and then when
you um use them dry before you get in
the shower dry and go upward motions
you're going to get your lymphatic
drainage and take the swelling down and
more energy and i need to do that yeah
that is amazing but like because yeah on
the road i just
it's you you got to feel good
it's got it's yeah it's and then also
someone sent these what are these called
sweetums
intimate cleansing wipes with flavor for
the vagina yes
or butthole with flavor but i'll
sometimes put it just like
i don't wear like deodorant because of
just all the
toxic stuff or whatever but i will
sometimes like i'll just like clean my
armpits a couple times a day i and i
love a good wipe a vagina wipes can
always double as
under armour under arms that's armpit
but i also realize that like the only
thing i need from a nice hotel is the
only difference between a nice hotel and
not nice hotel is the bath products so
i'm like i'm just going to bring my own
and save money 100 that's a hundred
percent because if they are exactly i
want to take them i just like yeah you
know i'll just start collecting them
also sorry this lip gloss do you know
this brand thrive
c-a-u-s-e medics i was just put it on
today it's the prettiest thing i've ever
seen that is linda color isn't that
pretty
you said that my makeup looked good when
um you came in that's what i put on yes
also what is this brand
uh
what is this brand
ingredients wellness this marula oil i
really like
is that i love that packaging packaging
is actually so cool i'm obsessed with it
ingredients yeah i love that i love that
um that's another oil i like do you know
about this isle of paradise self tanning
water no you have to know what you're
doing with it but it is a good self
tanner take it
it's a good like self yeah there's um i
can't think of the other brand that i
was using before but it was i shouldn't
out them it was like leaving weird
splotches and would exfoliate weird and
would start like building and i just
look like i had
weird basal cell skin disease melanomas
but i started using that as a self
tanning thing and it's a game changer
also i be remiss to not talk about my
magic root touch up which i use it's not
even so much to cover up little gray
hairs it's that i have do you feel like
oh see emily you do not have to you
neither of you has problem
i'm not i like i have thick ish hair but
when i put my hair up in certain ways
you'll just see it like a dash of scalp
no this is a real thing because i have
the most hair confidence on the planet i
have such thick hair jewish it's amazing
i love it but when i'm on a show
they when they always use that on me and
so i know like do this with your hair
like to put hat so i see some of your
scalp but it's not it's more because
your hair is thick no no it's it's just
it doesn't it's not an insecurity of
mine so i feel like i can speak on it
confidently it's like it everyone has
like little splotches and they have they
just cover it up for camera it's just
the way that your hair yes like that
side so for me when i just throw my hair
up and it's not brushed it'll look like
i just have like streaks of scalp
showing yeah so i use this uh this is
just the l'oreal medium brown and it
just you got to be careful though cause
sometimes you'll just be sitting and
talking and you'll kind of do this and
then you'll scratch your lip and then
you'll just be in blackface like you
have to watch it or if you're like
sweating it'll start melting down your
face which is a bummer i also have a
spot in the back of my head naturally
where like there's no hair that falls
and they use that up on me yeah this is
a it's called boom boom mint all natural
nasal inhaler is it like a
salt here just smell it's just like a
little bit it like clears your sinuses a
little bit and then kind of just like
perks you up
i love this i know i have like a couple
in my pocket i have like tea tree um
like to relax i have tea tree
tea tree toothpicks
and i'll sort of chew on those if i need
to chill out but that if i need like a
little pick me up yes boom boom mint
you're right is that good you weren't
lying yes
and it like claire like just makes you
feel oddly clear and awake yeah i like
that yeah because you know from here
it's good yeah so good yeah we just
tried smelling salts on on the podcast
and annie smelled it in for 10 seconds
it was so crazy
she yeah she's she will do wait smelling
salts like the ones that wake you up
when you're passed out yes the ones that
dave my fiance uses for serious
situations but we we try them for fun it
was it was honestly not does it get you
high it doesn't get you high it just
kind of like
jolts you awake yeah like because yeah
where are you on like
um
uh
uh
how do i say it drugs alcohol like
drinking
uh
recreational soothing like um
therapeutic benefits of things that can
sometimes get out of hand but if used
properly and responsibly can be helpful
yes so i
uh
i recently discovered weed
i love it
love it uh
dave is like you are go you need to act
like you've been here before because
you're acting like everyone i know when
they were 17.
but i i'm so excited about it i and i
you probably know this but i don't drink
i've just never drank i've never tried
it like for a million reasons um i just
never did but um
last year
when i had my miscarriage i had like
really bad pain after the surgery that i
had they have to have like an abortion
and the pain was so bad and i've always
been like really against any kind of
medication just you know whatever so but
i was like on the floor and they had
given me like emergency hydrocodone and
i was like i'm just going to try this
because and it and it helped so much the
stuff that's the liquid or the um pills
pills yeah
and it made me high and i felt so
amazing and i after that happened i
remember telling my guy friends i was
like i loved how that felt i wanted i
want more of that and they're like whoa
whoa whoa don't don't take more
hydrocodone they're like we think what
you want is weed so i started taking
edibles and
i i'm happy and then what is the what is
that when do you take them is it sativa
indica yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so and what because you know
edibles with me
i know don't jive
it's it's because my patience shit and i
think i probably take them for unhealthy
reasons i take them to anesthetize pain
not like relax
okay and then when i take an edible as
i've said before i just i my brain gets
dysmorphic and it tells me i got a dud i
don't yeah and you take too much i get
impatient i'm like i didn't it's not
working it's not you know i had bread
earlier so i need to take two more and
then like the way that they distributed
when they were being uh cooked or made
no i know yeah like my brain just tells
me stories that aren't true so i just i
can do it i like those little mints i
think it's like kevia or kevia's the
brand and they're like little manchester
oh the men's i'll take those on the road
like before i go to bed
and then so it's like it doesn't really
matter when they kick in yeah that's
kind of how it's leveled off for me like
at first like all people i first
discovered them and got way too excited
and i was doing it for a couple months
like a lot yeah and now i during the
pandemic yeah
but now i have like a rule with it i
only take them at night and i take like
less you know i'm i'm i take like 10
which probably sounds like a lot for
some people but i don't know what's that
yeah but 10 milligrams yeah oh 10
million i thought you said 10 yeah 10
milligrams that's not a lot and i think
also like you find what works for you
and then you get older and something
changes like the day i turned 30 i could
only drink tequila it was the only hard
alcohol i could without getting a
headache the next day you would love
shea mitchell's onda then because it's
sparkling tequila oh amazing yeah you
yeah we have to make sure you and brody
jenner just made a sparkling tequila as
well i don't ask i know that
and
um also joonshine just did a um so i two
hard kombuchas
i'm perfect but like i also um uh or
i'll do tequila
uh
like straight or with like a fruit juice
and then anything else gets a little
sketchy for me okay yeah so like man
it's about managing it or just knowing
like knowing what works and then going
like in a year maybe like white wine
just is like
migraine
sugar
i feel tired the next day like i think
also as you get older like
shit changes your relationship with
alcohol is very similar to my
relationship with food where it's like i
know
what i can do and what i can't do and
then what's going to make me hurt
totally not her it it and it just
changes you're like i just used to
fucking drink like mike's hard lemonades
all day and zimas and felt great but i
was like i'm not
20 anymore okay i love you same trash
tuesday it comes out tuesday all
tuesdays yes right and your episode was
one of my favorites people need to watch
you on our show
um we got into so much real shit like we
really we learned so much about yes the
sex talk with you is so good
you having the just i wish we had talked
about more sex stuff on that we'll do
another round and then doll face is out
now on hulu
cute as a button um yeah sleepover by
esther there's no point in even trying
to buy it it's all sold out
it's already sold out i thank you so
much for having me you are my big sister
forever and you'll never not be that no
matter how hard you try i love you
um yeah so this was fun okay good i hope
you don't get like all your problems
solved so you don't need me anymore
that'll never happen okay so anymore uh
i love you i end these awkwardly don't
write elephants we love you
esther pravitzki is my friend
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
you